1 attention luc ferrandez bonsoir
bonsoir là ça s'accélère pour vrai
dévoilement de ce qu'on perd mais c'est
la plateforme wii c'est quand même les
grandes lignes de la plate forme de
monsieur coderre lundi donc hier je vous
montre en graphique qu'on a l'impression
au pis j'ai hâte de vous en tant que
monsieur coderre tend vers madame
plainte et que madame plantes tend vers
monsieur codage parle d' en terme de
contenu de sorte qu'il est difficile de
distinguer les deux programmes monsieur
coderre parle de caméra portative au
spvm aucune rue sans arbres reverdir
registre de loyer
madame plantes également inspection
d'insalubrité obligatoires il reste deux
chiffres jouent pas dans ce film là il
dit vont pas de différence pitbull popu
de boules ne savait pas été très heureux
dans son cas là dessus alors première
question quelles sont les lignes de
démarcation entre les deux parce qu'au
niveau du contenu il joue dans les mêmes
thèmes annie baysa se ressemblent
beaucoup moi je dirais bonnet blanc
blanc bonnet long on dit on pense qu'ils
sont en train d'essayer de faire plaisir
à tous les citoyens de montréal la même
clientèle il se cherche cette clientèle
là et il propose à peu près la même
chose qu'on parle de caméra portative
suspect peut-être un dossier qui plus
prestigieux mais il reste des dossiers
lorsqu'on le vit comme il faut que j'ai
voulu regarder plaisir et puis je me dis
c'est qui qui dissipe je regarde de
l'autre côté c'est la même affaire on
est en campagne électorale fait que le
marchand de sable et la marchande de
saab ont la même poche de sang puis il
ya en distribue un peu partout on ne
jurerait après la pause où beaucoup
poussent à 2 l'intégrant pizza mais bon
l'udc est ce qu'il y a des lignes de
démarcation encore oui oui il reste
beaucoup puis après il faut voir dans
l'opérationnalisation déjà levé 20 20
c'est à dire l'obligation aux nouveaux
constructeurs de logements aux
promoteurs de
préserver du logement social mais ce
connard s'est dit en défaveur je vois
pas de plan cyclable de déploiement d'un
nouveau plan cyclable en cannage et
projet montréal mais lorsque valérie
plante s'est engagé à augmenter le
nombre de ressources en sécurité
monsieur code à lui répondu conversion
tardive
vous aviez pas le même langage il ya un
an on peut dire la même chose à monsieur
coderre conversion tardive dans
plusieurs dossiers mais tant mieux tant
mieux notamment dans le verdissement
mais attention le verdissement dans les
rues qui n'ont pas d'arbres ça veut dire
retirer des voitures suivantes et les
trottoirs ou si oui alors ça pour faire
ça c'est très difficile alors j'ai hâte
de voir mais au moins il proposait déjà
bien registre des loyers j'ai toujours
entendu monsieur coderre dire que
c'était pas de responsabilités
municipales jean n'était pas question et
là ils acceptent de s'engager alors
bravo monsieur kader et qui se rapproche
de qui le plus une chanson ça dépend des
dossiers mais pour le régissent le on se
rappelle qu'à l'époque où monsieur
coderre et marc projet montréal pendant
quatre ans déposer des motions posez
vous devez faire un registre des loyers
faut en faire le d'autres côté valérie a
été élu pendant quatre ans elle aurait
eu la chance de le faire malheureusement
pendant quatre ans elle n'a pas fait
elle non plus et curieusement ensemble
montréal a fait la même chose en disant
il faut un régime si fort et gestion
déposé des motions donc la bonne et
blanc bonnet blanc ils reviennent
aujourd'hui les deux sur la même ligne
de course pour partir la même ligne de
départ avec des promesses qui quand tu
es dans l'opposition 70 ans veut quand
on est au pouvoir tu le fais pas et ses
vice versa dans quelques docile bon
c'était à peu près le portrait connu je
vais vous présenter un petit reportage
vous rester avec moi de mathieu proches
parlait de verdissement le monsieur
coderre est parti là dessus pas de ruban
d'art et la limite entre montréal ville
montréal il veut enlever la fameuse
clôture verdir le boulevard l'acadie on
est quand on vient
c'est l'un des contrastes les plus
flagrants entre deux secteurs voisins
mais très distincts de montréal le
boulevard de l'acadie sépare la ville de
mont-royal du quartier parc extension
nous nous engageons à ce que le côté est
de l'acadie soit aussi jolie aussi
invita aussi vert que le côté ouest de
l'acadie ensemble montréal promet une
rangée d'arbres au milieu et du côté de
parc extension ainsi qu'une réduction de
la vitesse denis coderre veut aussi
s'attaquer à la barrière physique qui
sépare les quartiers ça veut dire
également de lever peut-être la clôture
1 on va travailler sur cette clôture
également valérie plomb de voix un
réveil tardif dans cette volonté de
verdissement et une ingérence concernant
la barrière il voit des ronds maire de
ville mont-royal quoi faire ça pour être
ar gall à laquelle on est habitué c'est
c'est moi qui va décider
la majorité du boulevard ainsi que la
clôture sont effectivement sur le
territoire de la petite municipalité et
ses candidats ne montre pas beaucoup
d'ouverture a retiré la séparation
physique je comprends pas le plein
d'enlever un clochard commentait ce que
ça va améliorer la qualité de vie des
résidants de parc extension ou pour les
résidents de ville mont royal notre
ville est accueillante alors c'est pas
de dire
qu'on se débarrassera jamais de cette
barrière n'a aujourd'hui selon il faut
parler si le réaménagement de l'acadie
qui n'a presque pas changé de
physionomie depuis les années 70 si
mathieu prost radio canada montréal
c'est monsieur coderre qui parle de
reverdir le boulevard l'acadie
excellente idée excellente
encore là ça sera pas tout seul à une
voie de circulation c'est minimum trois
points 5 m à 33 c'est un point 8 mètres
si tu veut planter des arbres et surtout
s'il ya des autobus qui paraissent sur
les côtés faut beaucoup élargir les
trottoirs et ça j'ai hâte de voir
comment ils vont le faire mais une
promesse de cette envergure là c'est
très très bien reçu à nice tension est
ce que finalement pasquereau beaucoup de
promesses qui vont chercher emblée on le
voit est ce que ces dames les qualités
de leadership les qualité d'exécution de
gestionnaires que j'avance à jouer
finalement mais ça va jouer ou et puis
aussi les premières c'est plusieurs
promesses qui se fond qui engage les
paliers gouvernemental provincial est
aussi fédéral vos du financement selon
vont prendre beaucoup plus de temps si
on pas été négociés ce qui va falloir
faire pour les citoyens c'est de
regarder vraiment ce qui est vraiment
faisable a qu un moyen puis à long terme
comme le phare la rue l'acadie boulevard
l'acadie à d'aussi que je connais très
bien quand j'ai été élu on a réussi à
faire enlever les portes avec les
voisins parce qu'il y avait des potes
qui se barre et le soir pour pas que les
pauvres de park ex peu salée jouer dans
les beaux parcs de mont-royal et la
vision avait changé lors de l'élection
avec une nouvelle mairesse on avait
réussi à dire qu'à faire vos statuts on
enlève des portes mais la clôture elle
est cachée par les arbustes soit qu'on
coupe toutes nos armes qui sont là puis
qu'on enlève la clôture parce que c'est
symbolique mais actuellement ce serait
ridicule d'enlever la clôture parce que
vous l'avez vu les arbres sont là mais
il va falloir être sérieux dans les
promesses puis les regarder parce que
les caddies ça sera pas en quatre ans le
honnêtement le temps de rentrer ça dans
le pays aller chercher les sous et tous
à ce propos a maintenant deux sujets
avant de vous laisser la piste cyclable
la sécurité des cyclistes se coderre ce
matin à dire il y avait eu plus de décès
ou d'accident on a vérifié nous montrer
le tableau tout à l'heure ses fonds le
ja il y en a pas de temps que ça mais à
chaque fois c'est un drame hier c'est
survenu avant
en mode camilien houde est survenu au
coin de mont-royal et avenue du parc on
voit les chiffres les n'ait pas eu plus
2021-2022 1019 il y en a eu il y en
avait eu en 2010 est bref luc ferrandez
est ce que est ce qu'on s'améliore dans
ce dossier là parce que les deux
candidats ont des bonnes propositions
oui on s'améliore mais pas assez vite le
tour de la façon dont le cycliste est
mort c'est que le camion a pris grand
tournant un tournant un grand-angle et
harvey avec force et vitesse sur deux
cyclistes il devrait pas y avoir une été
reçues et des intersections montréal où
tu peux faire ça ou un camion peut
tourner à cette vitesse là ça n'a aucun
bon sens alors vivement interpellé puis
avant de faire un terre-plein de faire
un fauteur play avec des jazz et de
béton avec des ballons avec n'importe
quoi mais cette intersection là y'a rien
qui a été fait parce qu'on veut la faire
grandiose puisque c'est l'entrée du mont
royal ça fait 20 ans qu'on veut la faire
grandiose mais là pas grandiose pour y
aller tout de suite avec les moyens du
bord
il ya aussi des règlementations qu'on
avait mis en place sur les camions qui
circulent en ville avec de mettre des
barrières à côté des portes pour poquet
deux jambes deux piétons de ce qui se
passait en dessous on le fait pour tous
nos camions de la ville de montréal on
l'avait exigé pour nos déneigeurs et
pour les autres camions qui circulent en
ville suscite encore on interpelle le
ministère du transport et les compagnies
camionnage mais ça ça pourrait déjà
permettre de régler quelques situations
qui sont assez fâcheuse est désastreuse
et quelques mort également et ça il va
falloir que l'administration pouce pour
pouvoir le faire rapidement aussi on
voit le au blanc madame blais qui avait
été amené également dans un vieil en
dessous d'un viaduc en quelques secondes
le stade de baseball est assez fascinant
monsieur coderre était plus tiède puis
madame plante était plus plus plus
enthousiastes face au projet quelques
secondes années
moi ce qui me fatigue là tu le sais que
les deux disent on veut pas en parler
pendant la campagne mais une annonce qui
s'en vient après l'élection ça veut dire
que s'ils savent qu'est ce qui s'en
vient honnêtement il devrait en toute
transparence le dire parce que si les
citoyens montréalais devront payer pour
ça serait bien de le savoir maintenant
pour qu'on puisse se positionner sur
notre vote et le les deux les deux là
dessus sont d'accord il ya une grande
annonce s'en vient mais on n'en parlera
pas tout de suite parce que c'est pas
nécessairement populaire parce que c'est
pas le sujet qui est le plus important
aujourd'hui la première préoccupation
des montréalais c'est le logement les
deux les deux candidats ont dit qu'ils
allaient faire beaucoup de logements
long priverait un quartier d'environ
4000 logements en construisant un stade
de baseball de centre-droit on est déjà
des stades à montréal est ce que
montréal n'a plus besoin de baseball ou
de logement la réponse est facile merci
beaucoup à vous du toujours très clair
salut à la très bientôt mon cher par
bonne soirée